call of duty infinite warfare is out
today but if you're purchasing the game
from the Windows 10 App Store you'll be
cut off from the larger Call of Duty
community I'm Lucy and welcome to your
mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall
GameSpot news update
according to Activision support website
multiplayer service for the Windows 10
version of infinite warfare and modern
warfare remastered won't connect outside
services such as steam it's one of the
questions listed on an FAQ page asks can
I play Call of Duty infinite warfare or
Call of Duty remastered for Windows 10
on Windows Store with my friends that
are playing on another PC platform
Activision's response basically reads
like this not in a million years
absolutely not
no way Jose no chance Lance nyet
negatory mmm nah oh and of course my own
personal favorite of all time man
falling off of a cliff I mean it
actually reads no you can only play
these titles with other users of Windows
10 on Windows Store it's effectively
cuts off infinite warfare and modern
warfare remastered players that acquired
the game from the Windows Store from a
community that activation has been
cultivating since 2003 we've contacted
Microsoft to find out whether there are
any plans to lift this restriction so
what do you reckon about the PC server
split let me know in the comments below
or come find me on Twitter I'm at Lisa
James games for more on infinite warfare
including how to unlock the Hofmeister
himself stay tuned to games